welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition in this episode
we're going to be getting you up to
speed on the birds of prey the DC super
team is making their way to the big
screen for the first time this year and
throughout the video we're going to be
discussing the members of the group the
best stories and everything you need to
know there may be some spoilers here so
if you don't want any surprises about
the group potentially roomed then I
highly suggest that you turn off now as
of making this video we haven't seen the
movie yet so these won't be in regards
to its plot but we also don't know if
aspects of this video will pop up in the
film for the same reason anyway if
you're still here thank you for clicking
the video now let's get into our birds
of prey breakdown birds of prey made
their debut in 1996 in the one-shot
comic book of Black Canary / Oracle
birds of prey by Chuck Dixon the
storyline featured the two titular
members fighting crime throughout the
world
it's an espionage type thriller
featuring an Aston Martin and canary
goes head-to-head with a group of
assassins that wish to kill an apparent
philanthropist named Nick Devine who's
building a dam into wonder Nick turns
out to be behind the entire thing Oracle
provides Intel and the two make a great
team up readers loved it and though
initially the core team was made up of
Batgirl / Oracle and Black Canary
they would go on to expand their ranks
in several ways but who's in the team
well though the lineup in the film is
made up of Holly Quinn Cassie Kane Renee
Montoya Huntress and Black Canary
a lot more have joined the ranks over
the years predominantly Batgirl / Oracle
and Black Canary
lead the charge on most missions before
her paralysis was retconned Oracle
provided the Intel and technical support
behind their missions and predominantly
she worked as the voice in the head to
guide them through crime fighting the
launch of the new 52 changed up the
severity of her disability after the
Joker's shot her in The Killing Joke
and since donning the cape and cowl once
more she has returned to active duty
Black Canary the other founding member
has been a staple of the group since the
start all the way up to present-day
Canary real name Dinah Lance
is a martial arts expert and she also
has metahuman abilities that have gifted
her with the ability to carry out a
devastating sonic blast from a vocal
chords this high-pitched shrill cannot
characters back and destroy objects if
used correctly depending on whether you
read the original Canon the new 52 or
rebirth canary has been in an on-again
off-again relationship with costume
vigilante Green Arrow and the two have
helped to build each other's skills
throughout the decades next up is
Huntress and similar to canary depending
on what run you read massively changes
up her origin story at one point she was
the daughter of Batman and Catwoman and
they have actually been several versions
of the character in comic book Canon for
this video we're going to be
predominantly focusing on Helena
Bertinelli as this is the depiction that
has been most widely accepted and it's
also the one that is being adapted on
the big screen Helena Rosa Bertinelli to
give her a full name initially started
off as an incarnation of Batgirl in the
run no-man's land
Batman distrusted her and forced her to
Don a new mantle and she picked up the
moniker Huntress which she found
criminals to be more receptive to
Huntress is the daughter of a mob boss
and after watching her family
slaughtered in front of her eyes she
vowed to put an end to the Mafia
Huntress is an extremely skilled fighter
and she also is an amazing shot with a
crossbow which has made her a strong
member of the team the next member will
be discussing his Harley Quinn and boy
where do I even start
dr. Harleen Francis Quinzel to give her
a full title first appeared in Batman
the Animated Series all the way back in
1992 she made the leap to comic books
the year after and has been a mainstay
since then initially the character was
merely the Joker's girlfriend but in
more recent runs she's broken free of
the toxic relationship and has turned
from a super villain into a sort of
antihero I was quite surprised that
Holly was brought over to the birds of
prey as predominantly she's a member of
The Suicide Squad and Gotham City sirens
what may happen is that she could be
tied to their origin story but end up
going her own way at the end of the
movie and leave the others to form the
team one of her best friends poison ivy
has been a mainstay in the crew and who
the movie could even introduce her as
being part of the group poison ivy is of
course one of Batman's most infamous
enemies and though she has also become
an antihero in a more recent depictions
she's still one of the most powerful
members of the teen ibeacon control
plants create terrifying ones that would
scare you out of mowing the lawn and
hypnotize people into doing her bidding
joining her in terms of the most
powerful members of the group is big
bada a former member of the female
Furies of Apocalypse completely lethal
Poirot was one of Darkseid's best
soldiers and after straying from a
master
she has become a defender of earth bada
makes appearances from time to time and
isn't a mainstay of the group but she
still makes an entrance whenever she
appears Lady Blackhawk has to be known
to join the team from time to time Black
Hawk was hurtled through time after
being part of the world war two team of
the same name and after landing in the
present she's become a valuable member
due to her skills katana has also made
many notable appearances through the
years and I was expecting her as part of
the group especially after her
introduction in Suicide Squad after
first appearing in 1983 katana has had a
countless number of appearances katana
is a samurai who carries the sword that
a husband's soul is trapped in and she's
a master at using the weapon most
commonly associated with the outsiders
she's also jumped across several times
to provide the birds of prey with
assistance over the decades Renee
Montoya was initially a detective from
the GCPD who was assigned to the major
crime units but after working alongside
Batman over the course of her comic book
history she ended up joining the birds
of prey Renee Montoya is actually a gay
character and over the years she's
become a strong symbol for the LGBTQ
community Cassandra Cain in the comic
books was the daughter of assassins
David Cain and Lady Shiva initially the
character couldn't talk but due to her
understanding of body language she was a
master at martial arts
Cassy could pretty much predict the
moves that you were going to make before
you even made them due to subtle
movements in your body unless she's one
of the best hand-to-hand fighters in the
DC Universe Cassy became Batgirl and now
it looks like the
depiction is different from this
massively I do hope it makes an
appearance in some form or another
there was also misfit who is a teenage
teleporter that completely idolizes
Oracle she joined the group as its
youngest member and though not often
listed as one of the most important she
definitely deserves her place there Hawk
and Dove are also big elements of the
team and Hawk is actually one of the
only men to ever be included in the
lineup the two characters symbolized war
and peace and bring a whole lot with
them when it comes to fighting the
forces of evil those are the most
notable team members and before we get
into the comic books you need to check
out I just want to let you know we're
giving away a free copy of dr. sleep to
one random subscriber all you have to do
to be in with the chance of winning is
like the video subscribe to the channel
and leave your thoughts on birds-of-prey
in the comments section below
the one is gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of February in the cell be
shipped out from the enter forgets the
price it's the best of luck to everyone
he takes part okay so if you're looking
for a place in comics to start with the
team that I highly recommend that you
pick up birds of prey the death of
Oracle although it predominantly centers
around Oracle who won't be in the film
and it doesn't feature Harley Quinn this
storyline delves into how the group
operate and also the psychology behind
them as you may guess it centers around
the quote unquote death of Oracle and I
definitely recommend that you pick it up
it's got pretty much 5 stars across the
board on Amazon so if the group is
piqued your interest and you haven't
read a storyline with them before then
this is the best place to start if you
just want an introduction to them then I
also highly recommend beginning a Batman
cataclysm and working your way through
the wrote in no-man's land before
tackling no-man's land itself
it's a massive arc that spans years and
should keep you occupied for a long time
if you want something a little less
weighty then why not give the 2002 TV
series a shot though short-lived and
only 13 episodes long it's definitely
worth diving into if you want to know
more about the characters the show
brings in Ashley Scott as Huntress and
pulls from the origin story in which she
was the daughter of Batman
catwoman dynami appears as oracle and is
also rachel's Garston as black canary
the series had a really interesting
premise and they picked up in the midst
of Catwoman's murder and Batman's
disappearance featured callbacks to The
Killing Joke and a lot more and you may
have even seen this world make an
appearance in the recent crisis on
Infinite Earths crossover before the
world was wiped out though it received a
lot of bad reviews at the time all in
all it's not actually that bad of a show
I definitely recommend that you give it
a watch as it's quite short and it has
enough of Batman and general DC
callbacks that'll keep most fans
interested anyway that's everything you
need to know about the birds of prey
make sure you say lock to the channel
for our full breakdown of the movie when
it releases
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the birds of prey as well as
which member of the team is your
favorite comment below and let me know
and if you enjoy this video then please
give it a thumbs up make sure you check
out our full breakdown of the leaked
plot on the movie it's a lot more
spoiler filled than this and definitely
worth watching if you can't wait till
Friday if you want to support the
channel from as little this 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below you get access to content early
and can suggest video topics and
breakdowns we massively appreciate it it
goes a long way to helping videos like
this get made you want to come chat to
us after the show either follow us a
definition whitey
click the discord link in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep up-to-date with heavy
spoilers so hopefully we see over there
very soon this is a channel for people
who are super into superheroes so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thank you for taking the time
to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]